how to sell the same thing for more
money by making offers so good people
feel stupid saying no the agenda number
one why nailing your offer will make you
more money than anything else
number two
why selling to the right people makes
you more money
more than almost anything else too
number three why you should charge lots
of money for the stuff you sell
number four how to reverse engineer
value and number five I have a pretty
sweet demonstration I'll do for you guys
how to use scarcity urges and guarantees
to make people want it even more
and charge more more and more double
more more money good all right so let's
start here
by nailing your offer we'll make you
more money than anything else so this is
my uh this is my big aha moment so this
is me when I was
23. uh just signed my lease super
excited arms look better there than they
do now but it's all good uh and uh had
no idea what I was doing I'd never sold
anything I'd never marketed never gotten
leads I had no
no clue what I was doing and so I spent
three thousand dollars of money that I
didn't have only at ten thousand dollars
at the time so I spent a third of my net
worth on a workshop that's supposed to
be a two-day workshop that was going to
teach me how to get leads and it was
this brand new thing that was on the
internet it was called Facebook ads it's
2013. I was super early this is where
luck plays plays a role so into this
workshop and I was there I didn't have a
real business yet because I wasn't open
and the guy pulls me aside and he could
see that I had no [__] clue what I
was doing I was like trying to take
notes but didn't even have context to
take notes with and uh he's like hey you
wanna know the secret to sales
that's my
faint Australian accent
um
he said uh he said
make people an offer so good they feel
stupid saying no
and that was actually the first thing
that anyone ever told me about selling
and so it changed my life and so I tried
to tell as many people as I can
because if you get that part right
everything else is easy
and I was very fortunate in that I had
somebody very early on who told me that
and so I tried to tell to as many people
as I can as loud as I can it don't
[__] book about it
and so I realized in that moment that I
didn't be good at sales good at
marketing I'm really good at anything
because I wasn't at the time I just had
to make my offer good enough and that
was when the greatest game of my life
began
and so for those who don't know it
offers what you literally give someone
in exchange for money all right there's
the product that's the stuff
the market is the peoples and the offers
the thing that Bridges those two all
right and so it packages and
communicates what you do in exchange for
the dollars
a shitty offer weekly connects to the
market
very little flow very shitty
or for some of you if you haven't made
sales yet that might be your problem as
well
so here's how you know if you have a
shitty offer number one it's hard to get
leads number two most people don't want
to buy number three if they do want to
buy they compare your prices to someone
else
no bueno
and here's why
what many people do is they try and just
well many people do is they try and
create another
and also ran right and what ends up
happening is that the prospect makes a
price driven decision rather than a
value driven decision and so they think
to themselves these two things are the
same I will therefore take the lower
price right and so we have to fight very
hard or very intelligently on how to
break that that cycle all right and so
this is what it looks like when it's
wrong these two are close enough I think
I'll get the cheaper one very sad for
all of us
a strong offer connects to the big part
of the market
so that you make more Monies so here if
you make and I'm going to show you cool
demonstration at the end of this but if
you can make an offer the entire
Niche that you're going after it's like
I [__] need this
then you're gonna have a lot easier time
getting leads a lot easier time selling
and a lot of times it's doing more work
than your competitors are willing to do
and that is what's going to shift people
to a value-driven decision which is I
really want this thing gosh it's
expensive but I don't think anyone else
could do it
that's where you want to be because then
you can make up your prices
great place to be in
and the reason it's so important for
making money is that when you get this
right number one you increase response
rates on all of your advertisements in
whatever way you advertise when I say
advertise I mean to make things known
number two
increase conversion so think sales so
more people that you talk to will say
yes to you if the offer is right number
three
premium pricing which means not only
will you have more people respond to
your ads and more people say yes but
they'll say yes at higher prices and
when you have more and more more you
make more and more and more money
so
right now my current return on
Advertising my career is 36 to 1. that's
not a typo our portfolio is a whole
generates over 200 million dollars a
year and a big part of that is nailing
the offer
and so nailing the offer is the single
strongest lever on your business success
so let me just show you how much so this
was a traditional agency offer that we
worked on ages ago but we just changed
one thing about the business model just
the offer we didn't change any of the
mechanics in the business what they
actually did nothing we just changed the
offer so what they used to do is they
were generic Facebook ads agency who
here knows what I'm talking about with
that anybody yes okay you know these
ones everybody has one your mom has one
your mom's basement has a kid in it who
also does it too right thousand down
thousand a month I'll run your ads for
you right
there you go we were doing Facebook ads
you get leads maybe maybe you don't you
pay us just the same pretty generic
pretty shitty offer
and so this is what their actual return
on Advertising was for their advertising
expense so they're spending ten thousand
dollars a month they reach 300 000
people the response rate between
Impressions to people who click
um they got 40 book calls from that
shortly 75 appointments who showed was
30 closing was 16 close five price
points a thousand so they spent ten they
made five so they're making point five
to one kind of shitty but 30 days later
they're at one to one and then so forth
right it's pretty normal and this is
actually pretty common in a lot of
businesses some of you guys may have
numbers like this right now
so let me show you a new way
so this is the offer that we changed it
to so rather than a thousand down a
thousand a month we said it's 4K down
one time setup no monthly fee and only
pay me when people show up
we'll run the ads for you and we had an
implied guarantee because if no one
showed up you wouldn't have to pay us
ever again obviously we're invested in
getting paid again we prefer to get paid
and so we will try and get as many
people to show up as humanly possible
cool simple
so same initial stuff spend ten thousand
dollars same number of Impressions three
hundred thousand
but
two and a half times the response rate
that's more number one
say now because of that response rate
the actual percentage stay the same now
we got 100 though of points about rather
than 40. and our sure remain the same so
now we have 75 appointments versus 30.
we would already call this a win would
you not this would be a win in your
business two and a half X cool
but then we got more and more because we
closed
2.3 times more people who got on the
phone
than we were before but we already had
two and a half times more people ah more
more second more
so we went from five sales
for ten thousand dollars 228 sales for
ten thousand dollars more money good
and the price point up front
went from one thousand dollars to four
thousand dollars
so we have two and a half times the
response rate 2.3 x the close rate at
four times the price
which resulted in a hundred and twelve
thousand dollars in cash collected up
front from that ten thousand dollars
which is 11.2 to 1 which from a
comparison standpoint was 22 times as
effective
just the offer didn't change anything
else
and so I say this to demonstrate one
thing which is that right now most of
you could dramatically improve your
offer and make a [__] load more money
cool
fantastic so if you went from whatever
you convinced yourself you're okay with
to ten times better row as would that be
interesting to you
fantastic all right so this is what you
will get from this presentation this is
the stuff you will learn if you actually
do something as a result number one more
leads for the same price two more sales
for the same call volume three more
money for the same stuff
so natural question is how so I'll spend
the rest of this President doing my best
damnedest to explain it all right so nil
number one number two why selling to the
right people makes you more money
so you want to see you want to sell to
people who are valuable because of who
they are
rather than who you are all right so
I'll leave you a little example so who
you're familiar with conversion rate
optimization cro anyone heard that term
it's basically people who look at your
website and say We'll change a bunch of
doodads and more people are going to
collect more people in opt-in okay very
simple in the Ecom world it's more
common than in the coaching world no
idea why when I say coaching I mean
Services Etc
um no idea why it is that way but it is
all right now so let's say you own that
and you work
on an e-commerce business is doing a
million dollars a year and you have a 10
increase in throughput which is very
common it's actually on the low end for
most cro agencies so you increase that
business by a hundred thousand dollars a
year that's value right and you charge
thirty six thousand dollars a year to do
that all right cool we got a 36 of the
value that you added neat
now let's say that you did the same
exact work
on a business that's doing a hundred
million dollars a year in e-commerce
get the same 10 increase you make them
10 million dollars more
now you can charge the same percentage
of the increase and you make 30 3.6
million dollars for that one job
same work 100 times the pay
who would like it 100 times pay increase
yes me too I'm with you all right and so
the big Point here is that
a lot of people think even the
offer itself has to be amazing which it
does but the next piece of this is to
make sure that we're presenting to the
right people so the same work occurred
in both of those scenarios but because
this person inherently was more valuable
we get paid more because we created more
value for them for the same work
that is leverage by the way the
definition of leverages you get more for
what you put in high leverage put a
little in get a lot out low leverage but
a lot and get a little out this is a
higher leverage play having a better
offer is higher leverage you do the same
work you get more responses you get more
sales higher prices is this making sense
cool
so this is a story that I like a lot to
drive this point on so Dad buys this kid
a car it's a clunker looks like this you
can imagine it right
and the kid's like I don't know if I
want the car he's like well you can
scrap it take the cash and you can put
it towards whatever car you want he says
okay he's like well where should I go
he's like well
why don't you go to the uh go to the
dealership see what they'll give you it
goes the dealership
says hey you know we'll give you we'll
give you five grand for the car he's
like okay so he goes back to his dad
he's like hey they said they'll give me
five grand he's like okay why don't you
go to the uh the pawn shop down the
street the scrap yard see what they'll
give you maybe the medal is worth more
this goes the scrap yard has same
conversation when I saw the car they
said we'll give you 500 bucks he was
like oh 500 bucks goes back to his dad
sulks and he's like they're only going
to be 500 for the car he's like okay
he's like why don't you go to that uh
that collector thing down the street
you already know where this is going go
to the collector's thing down the street
he's like hey I'm thinking about selling
my car and they're like dude
you have a historic blah blah blah
that's a hundred thousand dollar
there's only 20 of these left
comes back to his dad his dad's smiling
because he knows what happened and the
lesson he wanted to teach his son
is if you're not being
hello it sounded more dramatic that way
if you're not being valued it's because
of the people that are placing the value
on you and so a lot of times I feel like
we deal with this with a lot of like
again a customer segmentation that's
beyond the scope of this this
presentation but if you look at all the
customers you have there are customers
that pay you five ten times more than
your other customers right
but if you just had those
right it's a lot easier to make that
person more value because of who they
are not even because of who you are
right and so the person on the other
side of the table matters just as much
as this thing you're telling them
sometimes more
there you go the value derive is often
about who you find not necessarily what
you provide
and so this is a final little one I'll
drive this home with
so there was a guy who's broke down on
the side of the street
he was super upset big red car there
lots of fumes I don't know I have two
car examples but go with it and
and uh guys driving by stops on the side
of the road and starts pushing has
anyone seen this before in their lives
okay what's interesting is that this guy
who decided to be the Good Samaritan for
the day helped the other guy out nothing
crazy normal thing when he got back home
he found out
that the man on the side of the road was
a billionaire
and he had paid off his mortgage which I
think is really cool it's a real story
and so
it wasn't a function of what he did it
was a function of who he helped
so most people could push a car and
probably not get anything besides a
thank you which is fine and that's cool
because they didn't do it for that
but in this particular instance he got
his entire house paid off because of who
he chose to serve and so right now you
probably have pain in the ass clients
who [__] suck and you got a couple of
them are pretty cool
get more of them
and one of the hardest things in
business is being able to say no but I
promise you that if you're able to say
no to people who suck you'll make room
for people who don't suck and those
people will pay you a lot more money
thank you
facts
so
who do I decide to go after
if this is what I'm going to decide to
do awesome I'll give you a little
framework for this so when we look at
markets that we want to go after and
this is at a market level you can
actually drill close to this in terms of
customer segmentation
there's four characteristics we look for
number one is pain number two is
purchasing power
so do they have the problem to solve do
they got the money to spend can we find
them easily and are they going to be
bigger tomorrow than they are today
right because you could reverse this and
say how do I find somebody who doesn't
give a [__] can't afford the thing I
can't find them it's actually shrinking
right so let's not do that let's do the
opposite of that all right so
anyone heard this uh you might have
heard this example so if you have a hot
dog stand right and you're trying to
sell the most hot dogs so this is going
to be we're gonna do this live today
if you can just shout them out as loud
as you can because you have no mic and I
do
if you wanted to sell the most hot dogs
and we're in a contest and I said I'll
give a 100 Grand of the person who sells
the most hot dogs
what would be the one advantage that you
would want
[__] read my book
so normally I would go through this
they'd be like the best hot dogs the
best packaging the best
whatever right the best marketing
the answer is you want to be right
outside the stadium when the drunk crowd
gets out you want to starve and crowd
you can sell [__] inside of a bun as
long as it even resembles a hot dog and
you will sell out and so the idea here
is that we want to find the starving
crowd and the thing is is that within
markets there are sub segments that are
starving and they're wildly underserved
and they have lots of money and just no
one has done a good job by presenting
the right offer to them
number two purchasing power
so a friend of mine actually read this
book
um and like was going through this
process and
he was like I think I've got my perfect
audience it's unemployed people I help
them with their resumes they get jobs
this is a huge Marketplace it's growing
right
um
he gets on the phone with me after like
a month of this like crazy great idea
he's like you wouldn't believe it and I
was like tell me it's like they can't
afford a 300 consultation
it's like I I can believe it
and I was like what's the main reason
they're giving you you say they're
saying they don't have any income right
now it's like wild thought
and so when you're selling something you
want to make sure that the person you
have is purchasing power I will tell you
something that I've anecdotally found is
that the more I re I reveal about how
expensive something is earlier on the
process the more money out something
they make a lot of people like to hide
that and they try to like you know
obfuscate you know trying to like hold
it back and not tell people I don't want
to scare people off
people usually have an idea of a range
of what something is and if someone is
like so shock value that they won't get
on the phone they're probably not going
to close so I have been I've made more
money it has cost me more money per call
but I've made higher return on my
advertising by having that stuff but
most people are afraid of that because
they only look at the front end metrics
rather than the back end metrics
so number three is we want to find find
people are easy right and so
if they're not aggregated somewhere it
becomes very difficult to advertise to
them right we can't make our ship known
to them if we can't find them right if
you're trying to reach Rich doctors it's
much easier to do that than
I don't know something that some of you
guys are going after like you got to be
able to find this this is really
tactical but like this is why I love
niches when you have like associations
and Facebook groups and Professional
Services around this particular audience
it becomes very easy to Target them and
not only that it becomes easy to Target
them across all platforms and it becomes
easy to do outbound to them because you
can find those lists like there's so
many different ways to advertise to them
they get easy rather than thinking
creative innovative ways to do it
again there are other ways but why not
make it easier
like if we're going to do it might as
well just pick the the the deck steps in
our favor right
and so the last one is one that I
learned from Uncle Warren right which is
he tells a story that that has always
stuck with me
I said when I was at Columbia business
school he and it he had his closest
friend of Colombia
and they were kind of equivalent in
every way super smart really hard
working Etc
and when they graduated they went their
separate ways he went to get into you
know private equity and investing Etc
and his friend went into the steel
business and worked really hard et
cetera et cetera fast forward 30 years
his friend did decently well he you know
rose up in the company steals a hard
business they can't pay as well et
cetera this was an American Steel was
kind of in turmoil Etc and
um
two guys same IQ ish same same work
ethic Warren becomes an ultra
billionaire the other guy he's just a
normal dude
and he said that's when I learned how
important it was that it wasn't about
how hard you row but the boat you're in
and so a lot of us are are rowing in the
wrong boat and we're wrong as hard as we
can but we're actually in the wrong
vehicle and so when we're when we're
trying to pick the market that we're
going after you don't want to pick Steel
in the U.S when he was graduating from
college
a good friend of mine had a newspaper
business
he was a SAS dude from YC slick back
hair the whole thing looked fancy
and he was like dude
we're not growing anymore he's like I've
changed the the offer I've got you know
I've got my sales team he's doing all
this stuff
I was like bro
do you want me to say it he was like
what do you mean
it's like newspapers shrinking 25 a year
compounded against you not even like
neutral like negative compounding people
like 25 a year returns like do that for
10 years the other way very bad
and so he's like even though we're
gaining market share I was like yeah but
the Market's this big right and so the
thing is there's an old VC saying
ventric Apple saying he said when a
great manager meets a bad Market the
market wins right and so a lot of us are
trying we're rolling in the wrong boat
you're pursuing people who suck
if you go to places or you go to markets
that are growing
you grow by default there are some
people this is the nice thing that we
have is that we all just went through
covet whatever time ago it was
who here saw a big increase in their
business
who here saw a big decrease in their
well good for you guys for everybody
else
um
the point is is that you actually got to
see in real time the difference between
markets
like the market was actually behind you
and it got so much easier and so if we
have the ability to decide what we're
going to sell and to whom we might as
well stack the deck right so number one
why nailing your offer is the most
important thing that you can do to make
more money number two why selling the
right people makes more money did I make
that point cool all right number three
here's why you should charge a lot of
money for it aka the right price
one of my favorite quotes from Dan
Kennedy charge as much as you can
without cracking a smile
and so there's three little Frameworks
I'm going to give you as quickly as I
can because I want to get to some of the
cool other stuff
um there's price to Value discrepancy so
price is what you pay value is what you
get this is also a Warren Buffett quote
you can imagine the top line is the
value the middle line is the price and
when your value declines the point where
the price sorry the value Dives below
the price is where people cancel if you
have a recurring Revenue business or
people don't buy right and so every
single person wants a bargain this is an
important point you could sell something
for a hundred million dollars and it
could be a bargain
so price has nothing to do with the
discrepancy between price and value
there's both variables right and the
problem is most business owners focus on
the wrong side
and so there's two ways you can increase
that discrepancy number one the hard way
is that you can lower your prices right
if you lower your prices you increase
the discrepancy makes sense right it
also sucks because it's a great way to
compete on prices commodity remember the
apples and oranges we're doing the
Apples to Apples shitty life right and
what happens is you end up losing most
of your money
I have this nice visual didn't come up
okay it's all good
the other way to do this is the easy way
right is that you can compute on value
and create a value driven decision
rather than a price driven decision and
so this is where we start stacking as
many things as we can on this rubber
band of value to keep driving it as high
as we [__] can imagine so that the
price just follows as a result and so we
want to charge 10 times more than we are
now for something a hundred times as
valuable
I showed you an example of how we could
do 100 times more value just by serving
a better customer but does that make
sense
this is how you make tons of money is by
jacking the [__] out of the value so
much so that people are like this is not
the same as everything else I have
nothing to compare this to I have to
take whatever number they give me is the
only data point I have to compare to Dan
Kennedy said
you want to sell in a vacuum
no one else is in the room you're like
it's just you and me baby I'm all you
got right and so that's what we want to
do in our sales conversations where they
have no alternative there's nothing else
that they can do or nowhere else to go
or no one else who can solve this
problem all right it's remember this is
one that's always useful to remind
people of you can only go down to zero
like you can only go so low on the price
but you can go infinitely high in the
other direction on value
so I would want to tie myself to the
thing that I can infinitely go up on
rather than the one that I can only
compress to zero
so the goal is that they buy a
tremendous amount of value at a discount
we still want them to get a deal but we
do it by pushing the other side
the nice thing that happens when you do
this and this is what most people do
when they're picking their price so who
here has picked a price for something
they're selling recently can I get hand
thank you by the way means the world to
me that when you raise your hands when I
do that because it gives me feedback
Okay so
this is what most people do they look at
the marketplace they look what everyone
else is doing
number two
they see what everyone else offers in
terms of what they're actually providing
number three they take the average
number four they go slightly below to
remain competitive of course and then
they provide with their competitor
offers
a little bit more for a little bit less
right great value
what's interesting about that is that
they're looking competitors
and the funny thing is everyone's broke
you might not know this mushroom
competitors broke I see a ton of penile
statements every single day they come in
for acquisition.com so many businesses
broke as [__]
don't look at that they don't know what
they're doing why would you take the
average of the mediocre
right don't look at that they're poor
forget about it right there we go that
was that was the slot I wanted to show
you
what happens is when you have a
commodity driven or a price driven
Market we're offering
you continue to compete on price and so
what happens is everyone offers a little
bit more for a little bit less and they
keep going until basically everyone's a
non-profit everyone keeps their head
barely above water
one month's profitable one month's not
one month profitable is this am I
telling anybody their life story right
now anyone okay
and it's because you're playing the
wrong game
it's the wrong game
you have to be in a place where it
doesn't matter what anyone else is
charging because why would you want to
compete with them
then you have to be compared ah sucks no
fun right so we want to have a virtuous
cycle of price rather than a vicious
cycle or price because everyone's doing
a little bit more for a little bit less
then everyone can't do any more for any
less which sucks
so this is the better way call this The
Virtuous cycle of price
when you increase your price
your prospects
increase their emotional investment
they increase their perceived value when
you increase your price their results
increase as a consequence of their
emotional investment
their demandingness goes down
when you charge more anyone had the rich
client who just says oh yeah I set the
wire this morning and then somebody's
fighting you over fifty dollars anyone
else yes of course I'm a great client I
just send money am I just don't be an
ass thank you right
when you increase the price
I can't even ruin what it says revenue
for fulfillment per customer you make
more money so you can actually do better
[__] for them so you're actually in a
very real way get better
and the more you do this the more your
price goes up the more their emotional
investment goes up the more they value
it the better the results get the less
demanding they are and the more money
you have left over to continue to
reinvest in the value you can provide
them becomes a virtuous cycle right and
the flip side of that is that you
decrease your price they decrease their
emotional investment they decrease the
perceived value because they see you as
a cheap alternative they decrease the
results because they don't give a [__]
about it they become more demanding
because they're Cheapskates and then
finally you have less money left over to
provide value is this making sense
okay
and oh wait there's more your business
when you increase your price you make
way more profit right you feel better
because you're like I'm a good business
person I make money I'm good at this
game right so you increase your you you
increase your profit you increase how
much you feel about yourself your
perception of impact because the results
goes up because you're like I'm doing
good in the world not only am I making
more money am I good at business I'm
actually helping people because I have
profit left over to actually invest in
the value right
now our service level increases because
the people that I can attract as a
result
right because you can pay more people
like from a playlist thing and we have
sales team conviction and this is
actually a really underrated one
I've trained a lot of sales teams in my
life
the one thing that trumps all training
is belief
and if they believe the heart of the
founder the heart of the CEO is to
actually help the people that you are
selling to
they will sell with a completely
different frame
the best salesperson that we had in our
in our company at gym launcher we still
have
I have heard his calls
the man is a Savage like board like
psychopath
love you
I've heard him on calls after the third
or fourth objection and he'll just take
his dig his head off
and he'll rub his eyes and he's like
I'm not giving up on you Dad
he's like I I know you need this I know
you got a lot of stuff that's that's
preventing he's like but I know that
this is the thing that you need to get
to where you want to go
he's like so let's let's keep talking
through it let's figure this out man
it's like there's only one way that your
life's Gonna Change is through us like I
know everyone else's stuff I know you
got no other options like I'm your guy
so let's make this work and like I have
seen him do this again and again now how
many people on your sales team after
they get one objection they're like no
no you should yeah think about it
right because they don't believe because
if they really believed
this is a this is a really good example
so let's say that you could go back in
time to yourself and give yourself one
investing tip
just one
10 years ago
there's probably a stock or a thing or
whatever that was really small then
would be really big now probably change
your life right think of that thing in
your head
now imagine you go now but you don't
look like you but you're seeing your old
self 10 years ago and you're like
you have to do this thing and you can't
say that it's you
how convicted would you be to get them
to do the thing
they'd be like no I'm not really
interested I don't really know any of
that stuff you're like
you need to do this
you're like
come on man
the thing is is that that frame is the
frame of what good salesmen sell with
because they genuinely want the person
to do the thing to benefit
if you are the cheapest price and that's
not what you built your business
strategy around so I want to be very
clear there is a strategy for being the
low-cost leader virtually every person
who I've heard say that they're cutting
their prices to get more customers that
was not the strategy that started their
business with the only way you can start
that is your strategy is that from day
one you have a cost driven culture you
build a Tech Tool that automates a ton
of manual labor you take labor from
overseas exclusively you have a culture
of cost-cutting budgeting like Walmart
that's their strategy for virtually
everyone else there is no benefit to
trying to keep cutting your prices but
there's a very big one for being the
most valuable
you dig all right
quick one
so they did this science experiment
which I think is really cool and they
presented three wines to blind taste
testers
and they said they didn't say this
they're like there's a cheap wine
there's a middle price wine an expensive
one so those are the three wines they
people try them right and then after
they tried them they had them rate them
so they said
the the cheap one tasted like cheap wine
the middle one tastes like medium wine
and the expensive one tasted like great
one right
here's what's Wild
they're the exact same [__] wine
there is a bi-directional relations
between price and value
people if you want to in a very real way
increase the value that people perceive
about your product you can make it more
expensive and they will value it more
how nuts is that
it also makes it more money
right there's my head right blowing up
which means price itself is a component
of value
so the goal is to be so much more
expensive that a consumer must pause and
think this can't be the same category of
solution as everyone else
it's so much more expensive this can't
be the same thing right and then it
pulls you into another category so you
make a decision or you force them to
make a decision in a vacuum all right no
if you have any kind of service this is
more for services if you have a service
where a client has to perform something
in order to be successful then it would
follow that the more invested they are
the more invested they'll be which in
turn creates better students and better
outcomes
so like if you want to help someone
you have to charge them enough that it
would hurt them so that they actually do
it
the most the most successful weight loss
offer I think of all time I am a little
bit biased was the one that we ran for
gym launch
it's called the six-week challenge
here's the stick people would come in
we would say Hey you can lose 20 pounds
in six weeks you put 500 down
if you lose the weight you get the money
back
everyone had real skin in the game
there's a number one offer for the
entire industry for almost five years
because it was so compelling compared to
like a membership or whatever [__]
thing that was out there
and when we did that we had 78 of people
succeed
and hit the goal people were like oh is
this shake that you like no one hit it I
was like no people want to get their
money back the stick was that most
people need to lose more than 20 pounds
right or when you lose 20 pounds you
look yourself in me you're like I look
pretty flat and you're like right you
should tone up we should do the rest of
this stuff right so that was the thing
but they believed that we could help
them because we did and we got them
invested more than a traditional gym
membership was remember we're competing
against 29 memberships so 500 is very
very expensive does that make sense
think about how you can apply this
within your own business to separate and
create another category
right so
when you charge more you also as a side
note increase the quality of your
prospects
which increases the quality of your
product
like I said earlier with the cro example
if you increase the prices it takes all
the shitty people out and then by doing
that you only get people who are smarter
more able et cetera and then all of a
sudden your percentage results go up
because you're dealing with the right
people right don't have to sell to
everybody
so we actually did this with one this is
a different weight loss brand one of our
portfolio companies they were doing 450
000 a month
five to one row as close rate was 30
percent
profit was about 150 000 a month
and so we made one change to the
business
I looked at everything I was like
we're just going to raise your price by
50 and change nothing else
it was like what about all the other
like
let's just do that
it's like really like that's that's it
that's what we're gonna do like of all
the levers we have
in percentage like I'd already done a
bunch of research on other people that
are competitors Etc I was like I think
the price the market can stay sustain
this
here's what's crazy
went to a million a month
within eight weeks
went to ten to one row as
their close rate went up
and their profit almost tripled in eight
weeks
because people believe that the thing
was going to be worth more
and they got better results as a
consequence and they got better people
to buy
there you go so 2.76
or six seven okay that's why you should
charge a lot for it so making making
offers or making more money than
anything else number two while making
while selling the right people will make
you more money number three why you
should charge a lot of money for it
number four
how to reverse engineer value I'm gonna
do it on time okay so
I'm gonna go over
is that cool is that all right okay
so if you're gonna charge a lot of money
for it you might as well make it
remarkable
so this was our gym Lords event
there's 700 people in this room
42 000 here each
wild right so my dad saw this picture on
Facebook cost me out and he's like hey I
saw that event I thought it was supposed
to be like for your really expensive
highest paying people
I was like it was
he's like no the one that was like 40
000 a year I was like yeah it was
like do they know
that you're that you're charging them
that money and I was like yeah they're
aware I'm not magically siphoning money
from their account they're aware
but like blue is I couldn't couldn't
fathom it right it's 28 million dollars
right there
and so
it was like okay
so I could this was like a teaching
moment right
so I was like all right well
I'll bet you that you would pay me that
amount of money too
he's like what I was like okay so let's
say that I could triple the profit of
your business because he's a small
business owner he's like okay I was like
and
I would uh and I could do that he's like
well
what would I have to do
it's like you'd have to show up 10 hours
a week more than you currently do he's
like okay I could do that
it's like well
had anyone like would anybody else have
already done this thing too and I was
like yeah 4 000 people would already
have gone through the same process
that's what I would be taking you
through
it's like
how long would I have to wait
it's like about a year for you to get I
was like it would be eight weeks for you
to Roi and then 12 months yes
okay well then you know what we're gonna
do value equation is awesome [__]
rocks there's four variables you got to
charge something that's uh have a dream
outcome that's amazing you have to
increase the perceived likelihood of
achievement which is the questions my
father was asking me you have to do it
as fast as you can you have to make it
as easy as possible if you think about
those four things within the value that
you're charging you will make something
more valuable so good fast cheap easy
so how can you make it easier how can
you deliver it faster how can you make
sure it's something they actually want
and how can you increase or decrease the
risk that they associate with the
purchase does that make sense okay
so lots of variables lots of da very fun
there's a whole process to this exciting
cool
everyone understand how to reverse
engineer value
fantastic
so we got two left or this is the one
left
so here's my quick recap I haven't
understand why making a better offer the
strongest level you have to grow your
business yes
number two and you can say yes back does
everyone understand that a big component
of values picking the right people say
yes
does everyone understand the direct link
between price and value and that
increasing of both increases the
perceived value and your profits say yes
number four does everyone understand
that value isn't an amorphous word but a
formula that can be repeated over and
over again say yes
all right
last piece is a demonstration so I said
five minutes there we go we're good
there we go so how to use scarcity
urgency guarantees bonuses and naming
there's a lot of other things you can do
to enhance the value and get more people
to buy your [__]
I obviously can't do it in the next
three minutes but I'm going to do my
best to give you a demonstration all
right
so we're going to do an exercise to wrap
this up and I think it will do more any
we'll do more for you than anything I'd
say with slides okay so I'm gonna sell
you a book for 100 grand cool
excited
fantastic just kidding 100 a thousand
dollars
here's the directions
the moment you feel that a thousand
dollars of value has been created please
stand okay
thank you
100 just kidding type off a grant
let the value building begin so
I have a really good book and I will
sell it to you for a thousand dollars
who would like it
okay fair enough
at least and if that was worth it
it's a best seller
does that change anything no okay that's
fine I find I gotta get my work set up
it's my book
one I got one two three there we go all
right I'm feeling it thank you
it's got almost eight thousand five
stars
worth a thousand yet where's that okay I
see you it's been number one four and
seven bestseller for 13 straight months
still
worth a thousand bucks yet maybe maybe
not this guy 4X
his monthly Revenue this guy reads a
book a month
he said that was his book of the year
and he quadrupled his Revenue at his
business just from reading that book
worth a thousand bucks anyone stay
standing stay standing stay standing
stand I'll repeat the directions please
stand and stay standing if you think the
book's worth a thousand all right
if I autograph the book
do I have my markers area
we do have markers so
right now there are only six autographed
books including one that I did earlier
in existence is it worth a thousand
bucks yet
wait
I'll also put my personal cell phone in
the book
I have 10
I have 10 of these
all right
got some standing weight
I'll also review four of your sales
calls including your sales management
meeting which right now we can usually
get a 30 50 boost in sales across your
organization and I'll include it with it
is that worth a thousand bucks
we'll also have my traffic guy right now
we do about 20 000 leads a day across
all of our portfolio companies so my
traffic guy look at your entire funnel
it's usually about a 10 to 11 page
write-up we'll look at every vsl every
video every ad end to end and we'll give
you the whole write-up everything you
can do to get more traffic in which
normally will more than two accent but I
feel confident too
or a thousand
all right
we'll also use my network from Layla's
process to find the person in your
business that is missing who's the thing
that's going to unlock the growth that
you need
please stand if it's worth a thousand
fantastic I'll also spend two hours with
you going over your offer one-on-one
to figure out a way to use all the stuff
that we said here some Judo tricks that
I didn't share uh
to make to get you more clicks more
sales at higher prices worth a thousand
I'll also feature that two hours on my
show which right now gets about 10
million impressions
which the ad space sells for about a
hundred thousand dollars an episode I
got it given to me and I said no
um but about 100 Grand per episode in
Impressions so I'll feature you on that
show that's just for 90 seconds you'd
get the whole thing
please stand right I'll also guarantee
you three times whatever you paid me
over a 12 months that's the fine print
over 12 months is that fair
worth a thousand
and um
there's only one book
not ten
so look around
real quick
you can I can see your heads you're not
looking look around
tell yourself 25 book for 100
so please stand and stay standing
does everyone understand how you can use
scarcity urgency guarantees bonuses and
naming
to increase the value of the thing you
sell yes
does everyone understand how now you can
use this offering to provide more value
sell to better clients for higher prices
and higher volume
yes
so great you can take your phones out
real quick
thank you
foreign